okay but inequality is inevitable is it
not and well that's another thing i
wanted to talk to you about well let's
talk about that and because
i had this client who was a mathematical
genius clinical client he taught me a
lot of things i didn't know i hadn't
learned as a statistician and one of the
things he talked to me about was the
pareto principle and so i went and
looked into that in some depth and so i
found for example that
it's so such a strange phenomenon it's
like
the square root of the number of people
operating in a specific discipline
produce half the output
that's the law and so there's a thousand
scientists working on a particular in a
sub dis in a discipline 30 of them
publish half the papers
and you can look across it's the same
with basketball uh hoops successfully
managed hockey goals scored soccer goals
scored records produced
books written books sold
records sold it's like everywhere this
this law this weird square root law
sometimes people sum that up as the 80
20 principle but yeah it's way worse way
i heard it yeah it's way worse than that
yeah it's way way worse than 80 20. yeah
well it's it implies for example if you
have an organization with 10 000 people
100 of them doing half the work
you know if you have 10 it's three and
that's not so bad but at ten thousand
it's a hundred and you think no way it's
like well if you meet some of those
people who might be in that hundred
you'd you might think differently
so
and this looks like this some
fundamental rule and so
you're interested in income distribution
and so
what do you make of this sort of thing
well it reminds me of a classic paper by
the late economist sherwin rosen
university of chicago called the
economics of superstars
and he starts it out by observing 80 20
like observations by you know
let's look at the earnings of tennis
players and look at the rank
so how much total
prize money is won by tennis players and
what proportion of it goes to people
based on the rank and he gets something
like an 80 you know the top you know 20
or 25 tennis players have taken in you
know the vast majority of the winnings
and it you know record sales by um
musicians in various genres of musical
production and whatnot similarly the top
ones are getting
so he says how can we account for this
and
uh
this i think should be a part of
anybody's effort to explain uh the uh
pareto principle as you've uh defined it
or the 80 20 rule
he says
look
to
produce um
something that people want to see you
need talent but you also need other
resources and so it's the combination
of the productivity of the talent which
is scarce and distributed in the
population and
the effectiveness of their ability to
command other resources which taken
together
determine
what they will be able to produce
all right so you need a combination so
imagine one distribution would be talent
and so you need to be in say the top 10
percent but that's not enough you also
need i don't know you need to be in the
top 10 percent of education say to be a
successful research scientist and the
juxtaposition of those two curves
produces a real fractional percentage
and those people are hyper qualified for
that particular enterprise
he adds another element which is let's
take opera singers he uses this example
so in the old days before you had high
quality
sound reproduction such that you could
sit in your living room and listen to a
recording of an opera singer
through your speakers that produced an
effect that was almost as good as being
in the opera house before that before
that
you had to actually go to the opera
house to hear opera now the opera house
can only accommodate a couple of
thousand people
max so
the very very very best opera singers
could still only command an audience of
a couple hundred hundred thousand people
in any given performance which leaves
plenty of room for the second third
fifth and thirtieth best to be able to
travel to the small towns and still make
a living
but once it becomes possible for the
best to record their uh performance and
to distribute it in that way the person
sitting in the small town has a choice
do i go to here at 20th rate opera
singer in the local
hall or do i put a
recording of the best one on my device
now
often they will choose to go with the
recording rather than to go to the 20th
best and that means that the top opera
singers are now going to command an even
greater
share of the market and the insight
there is that technological change which
permits the most talented to lever their
talent to a larger audience is the key
to understanding why they get
so much of the of the take
completely right right well you can so
it's like
the smaller the game
the less the gain at the top but we
expand the games continually with
technology and recording is an excellent
example of that and so i guess what we
hope is that we produce enough new games
so that everybody can win at something
but we're still we're still funneling a
tremendous number of resources to people
at the top of whatever the game is
especially as these games become big
so
can you see that you see that particular
well it's really obvious with money and
people complain continually about the
top one percent but the problem is is
that
there's a book called big science little
science that was written in about 1962
and the author escapes me at the moment
but he did exactly the same sort of
analysis for the scientific literature
it's exactly the same story
so hyper dominance of a tiny minority of
people and so there's a natural it's
something like positive feedback loops
too isn't it because and i've noticed
this as i've become more famous i
suppose is that
you get known and some more people know
you and so more people are likely to
attend you and then more people are
willing to talk to you because you have
an audience and so that drives the
expansion of the audience and your
connection network grows at the same
time and you have more resources and so
it just it's a pause it's a bunch of
positive feedback loops moving upward i
think the word network is very important
there and i i think what with social
media and whatnot
and and uh the
magnifying the ability of individuals to
uh have influence and uh to have
influence on people who have influence
the the density of that network is a is
a tremendous asset for uh
uh you know
yeah so it makes its competitive
position well it makes the problem of
inequality a real tough one from the
political perspective right because we
could and conceptual for that matter
because we could perhaps agree that
regardless of whether you're on the left
or the right you might view inequality
on the right as a threat to social
stability so i know there's this uh
native canadian tribe on the west coast
haida the quack quackwacks did the same
thing
you know in their societies they'd have
big chiefs and
the big chiefs would just accrue
everything
and then now and then they'd have a
potlatch and give it all away and then
their status was dependent on their
ability to give a lot away
and that stabilized their society now
those were made illegal by the canadian
government i think about 70 years ago or
so but you know they were thought of
just some pagan
an unnecessary pagan ritual i suppose
but
i do believe that that was one of their
so-called evolved solutions to the
problem of the terrible problem of
inequality the fact that you know goods
tend to accrue in the hands of a few and
and the lefties that i see the left
political thinkers economic thinkers as
well
especially the ones on the extreme left
they tend to associate that with
capitalism but that's a fundamental
underestimate of the magnitude of the
problem in my thinking and
that's a real problem if you're
concerned about you know comparatively
poor or actually poor people
way bigger problem i wonder if we could
apply the same kind of thinking that we
use to explain why uh
athlete or a musician or even an
entrepreneur might end up uh
at the very right end of the
distribution
garnering for themselves a great bulk of
the of the reward
to apply that to the huge financial
fortunes that
um are uh accumulated either through you
know savvy in the marketplace you know
i'm a hedge fund guy i know what to buy
and when and when to sell
or to uh the the fortunes of land
holding you know
family uh fortunes and things of this
kind
um i i i wonder whether those simple uh
insights uh
extend to the
institutionalized wealth generating
process well i think i think they do to
some degree i mean i studied
entrepreneurial success as a researcher
for quite a long time too because
one of the personality factors that
predict entrepreneurial ability is this
trait openness which is essentially
creativity and
what defines creative thinkers in part
is so here's a simple creativity test
and it actually is reasonably predictive
of creative capacity both in terms of
originality of thought and creative
productions as assessed by experts how
many uses can you think of for a brick
in three minutes gotta write them down
or even how many four-letter words can
you think of in a minute that start with
c
that'll be correlated at about point
three or four with your creativity
depending on how it's measured very
simple test and what seems to happen is
that creative people when they think of
one idea
the probability that that will
trigger an associated idea is higher
especially a distally associated idea so
that likely means that creative people
have more erroneous ideas as well
and then they have to you know what
would you say edit them and select but
one of the things that makes creative
entrepreneurs successful
is that they produce a large variety of
creative products and then they throw
them out in the marketplace and most of
them fail but you just need one to hit
that pareto point and then you're
successful so you throw you know it's
you throw some what do you do throw a
mess at the wall and see what sticks
essentially and most entrepreneurs
before they're successful have had a
very large number of failures because
even if you're intelligent and creative
the probability that you'll build a
product that's actually timed for the
market is extremely low
so well what do you do well you create
more and that's what happens that's what
creative people are essentially
biologically predisposed to do
so i think that yeah i think that
principle
that underlying principle of positive
feedback loops and you know the
combination of scarcity of of of ability
and resources i think it accounts for
all those
inequalities so you know question is
what do we do about that well you were
saying something i thought interesting a
moment ago about how even a right winger
ought to be able to see that inequality
uh un
restrained could be dangerous to the
stable social order because the losers
losers are going to end up having to say
one way or the other at the end of the
day and you better watch out because if
they don't have a stake in the system
and they're feeling aggrieved and
uh without status and dignity uh they
may act out in ways that are hard oh
they will especially if they're young
men absolutely they will they absolutely
they will and that is definitely
dangerous and so you know partly we've
tried to solve that so to speak we in
the west by
trying to ensure something like equality
of opportunity across a wide range of
games that's not a bad sort of meta
solution right it's like well we can't
predict we know that there's going to be
wild disparities in outcome and we can't
really do anything about that but maybe
we can give people something
approximating an equal shot at winning
some game
and that would be better for everyone
too because then we can harness their
creative resources and it isn't obvious
to me that there is a better so
technically even i can't see like i
don't understand
i don't know what a better solution
could be no what does that mean in a
world where the people who have
engineering degrees or gotta got to law
school or
uh got a good uh uh you know education
and and are connected are making six
figures
and living comfortably and and someone
who dropped out of high school is
working for thirty thousand dollars a
year and just barely getting by what is
that ladder guys venue where uh he or
she can feel like they're winning the
game
well i think it depends to some degree
on each individual you know i mean you
can find status and meaning in your
family
you have your pursuits outside of your
work i'm not saying that money isn't a
good singular marker of relative status
it's probably the best singular marker
there is but it's not the only one right
there are diverse there are diverse
places where you can attain status
and so and you know you know you can be
poor and dignified you've certainly met
people like that you you can be poor and
admired within your family you can be
poor enough decent or outstanding
character for that matter and
so
and that's how
that's not exactly a domain that's
regulated socially like the economic
domain but it's not nothing
and so and by the same token you know
you can sacrifice a lot of those things
to economic pursuit and then you'll have
lots of money but man your life sucks
and in 50 different ways
so
i don't know if that's a sufficient
solution but it's not nothing
but this is not counseling laissez-faire
if i understand it it's not saying the
government should just withdraw and let
the chips fall within may
it could be a poli advocating for a
policy of some kind of you know
everybody needs work that's meaningful
uh you know everybody needs a kind of
sense of security you know that they're
not going to get sick and not be able to
pay the bill or they're not going to get
old and not know where the next meal is
coming from
let's guarantee let's try to guarantee
to the extent that we can we know it's
the world's not just uh perfect and we
may not be able to solve all these
problems let's
let's try to make sure that there's
decent housing for someone that's not so
they don't have to sleep under bridge
etc etc and then let then we can let the
chips fall with it yeah well it seems to
me that societies like well the us to
some degree but more specifically i
would say the scandinavian countries and
probably canada would more or less fall
into that
what ballpark and we fall into a
ballpark it's pretty bad metaphor but
you know that's kind of what what those
democratic socialist countries have
tried to
establish now it seems to be easier to
do that in a smaller country that's more
homogeneous in its ethnic and racial
grouping and maybe also technically it's
easier with a smaller population you the
u.s is so damn big
it gets very complicated to try to do
the same thing you know that those
smaller qualities have managed and and
then of course there's
because you might think of something
like a guaranteed a guaranteed income
let